Danny, thank you so much for being on my show, 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
I'm doing great. Thank you for having me.
Definitely. So, we edit this up.
But a second ago, I said thank you for having me on 20 Minute Leaders.
You know this is actually the 75th or so episode that we're recording.
So you would think that by then, I would know how to introduce people.
Well I guess that's not just the case.
Danny, really really interesting guy that I'm really excited to get to know you better
over this next 20 minutes or so.
You worked on a marketplace at called Saily,
with the good friend of mine from the Til Summit,
Forbes 30 under 30, now Forbes Tech Council.
Talk to me a little bit about where you come from
And how you even got into this entrepreneurial world?
Yeah. Well, I come from a very far country in the Middle East, called Lebanon.
And, this story actually started 10 years ago.
But we have time, I think.
Yeah.
Yeah. So, of course as a child, I was just obsessed with computers.
Even before the internet.
So, we just got our first computer when I was seven years old.
But I was more interested in creating, rather than just consuming
Like playing games or what's fun.
But I wanted to build something.
So, the only tool I had back then was Microsoft PowerPoint.
And I just kind of find a way to build a simple games.
Like just multiple questions games on top of that.
And this was my first encounter to programming.
Later on, moving forward. I just went on to computer engineering program.
But I quickly realized that they're not teaching us anything practical.
So, what we learned was theory.
And I wanted to build websites, mobile apps
The iPhone just came out and mobile apps were just very very early stage
and I remember I just couldn’t afford to buy a MACs
So I went in and work as a waiter, a Barista actually, at a coffee shop.
Wow.
So I made enough money to buy the MAC
And then the first thing I thought about is
Let me just built an app for them, for the coffee shop.
Wow. And then I just sold it to them and quit.
And started pursuing my career as a software engineer.
So you went from a waiter to building an app for the coffee shop
and then quit as a waiter and you--
Okay. So, then how do you get to--
Let's pause a little bit to Saily.
How do you get to building this really incredible marketplace
where in the end you actually merged with Mercari, right?
Yeah. So, for Saily actually it was just Hackathons at the beginning.
Hackathons were still new concept
I just went there.
I won the first hackathon for some reason.
And then met this guy, he was just 15 years old back then
but he was just very bright and we decided to team up.
And started hacking the judging criteria and making some prizes,
cash prizes [--]
At some point, one of the judges was like,
"Hey you guys, I see you all the time in those hackathons
just playing and doing nothing about it.
Are you gonna built something?"
And we were like, "Yeah. Let's do it."
So we just bought a ticket. Flew to San Francisco.
And this is how it all started.
And Saily was just the last idea that won the competition.
It was just a marketplace to buy and sell secondhand items.
So, Saily was actually a hackathon, it was a hackathon idea?
Startup weekend idea. Yeah. That's true.
Oh, very cool.
And then it just started growing.
Things worked out also somehow.
The timing I think was very good because mobile apps were just on the rise.
And it was kind of like a mobile eBay at that point.
And lots and lots of competitors were building those kind of apps
at the same time, and raising hundreds millions of dollars
just to grow it up to something.
Like offer up even before LetGo.
Even much way before Facebook marketplace and all of those.
So, what year are we talking about?
So, Saily it was the marketplace to buy second hand items.
And the timing was good for it to grow.
And then after six years of working on it,
we ended up with joining Mercari.
When did you start working on it?
Back in 2013.
2013.
Yeah. Oh wow.
Okay. That's really an interesting time to start building mobile apps and marketplaces.
Exactly. Exactly, yeah.
We didn't know back then, but
Of course. Of course.
And what was that experience? You know growing the app from one user yourself
to 500,000 users?
Yeah. That was very exciting times for us.
Because we learn as we were going.
We were just growing finding new ways to do user acquisition
to find our target market.
Who are the people who are gonna use it.
To fight fraud and scammers.
We were scammed a lot at the beginning
Like those fraudsters but we learned as we--
You know, you lose a lot of money but you learn.
Tell me about one of those scams.
What were you scammed with?
So, usually they get stolen credit cards
And they buy expensive items of our platform.
They finish the transaction.
And then, at the end of the month
Stride would be sending us a dispute saying,
"Hey, this credit card was stolen.
We're gonna take the money out of your bank account.
Wooh. Okay.
Stride didn't have fraud detection by then.
It was just very early.
So we had to degrade with other services to forget that out.
But by then, we've lost like $20,000 or something.
Just because there was a delay before we knew it was happening.
So you know. About marketplaces, you need both ends of the stick.
You need both salaries and the buyers.
Right. And you need them upscale in order to really
you know, build a good experience.
So, how do you go about even strategizing how to get
to get really the sellers on this platform.
Exactly, yeah.
Well, what we did was we started at specific cities.
So, New York city for example.
And even targeting specific kind of people.
San Francisco, the techies.
Like you know each area with high population
has a good amount of people that usually sell and buy specific items.
And this is how we initially started then.
Then, it just expands as you go and grow.
But the initial part is the hardest part to get.
Definitely. I'm Sure.
Okay, so then you go and you're building this amazing platform.
How many people are you on the team?
We were a small team of five people.
We didn't want to hire people just for the sake of ethics.
Like showing that our company is expanding or growing.
And we are very good at fast execution.
And getting the best out of every single person.
So were doing at least the work five to 10 engineers for example
in another company. A big company for example.
It's just the tools that we built.
Like we built abstract layer later on which got us into for say under 30.
That was mainly because of Saily.
We were like--
So, what is abstract layer?
Okay. So, it's an automation platform.
We realized that we're building those components and features for Saily
And a lot of things are just very similar if you look at it from a high level.
So those are cabled UC that you scrolled through,
or [-], or the data showing and interacting with it is very common
across different apps, across different screens.
So we just thought about an abstraction to it.
Where instead of writing down or coding stuff
you can just do it in, let's say two lines of code
You can just do what thousands lines of codes could do.
And then this allowed us to build product and features
and everything else. 'til today I'll still use it.
With our new startup.
It allows us to go in execution from something that would take a month
will take three days.
And this a huge to anyone whose pursuing startups
And trying to build fast.
So, is that a package or a product? How does it work?
Exactly. It's a framework where you just drag it into your export project
And in our case which for IRC.
And then out of the box, it has so much things that you can do
to just build the same data, combining and viewing and interactions in seconds.
Right. Okay. So, then so you build abstract layer and that gets you on
on the Forbes 30 under 30. Congratulations.
And you're on 30 under 32, right?
Yes, yes. We can talk about you later.
In another time. Thank you.
I can interview you.
Sounds great.
And then, what is this Forbes Tech Council that you're a part of?
So, Forbes Tech Council is, they have very strict requirements to get in.
Whether it’s on your startup revenue or net worth
or whatever the criteria is.
And then once you get in, you start contributing to Forbes Tech.
So, you're writing tech articles. You're doing consultancies.
And there's also a huge form where everyone from the industry are asking questions
and everybody is giving their experiences.
Right. So, it’s a huge network.
Actually, it's a small network of successful entrepreneurs
and people in the tech industry.
that can help each other and help others by just sharing their knowledge outside.
[-]
So what do you usually write about?
What do you enjoy writing about?
So, for me it's all about engineering productivity for example.
Really. I love that. Yeah, of course.
So, anything from a building tools to help you from the mentality,
how to schedule your day, what kind of things to tackle.
So, I care a lot about having just one engineer on my team
that can be 20x as others.
Just like people who are employed at companies and are doing what they're told to
without even thinking of, how can we make it faster?
How can we build even better things?
Definitely. So, you know I'm an engineer by profession as well.
How do I increase my productivity and to any other engineers
that might be interested in this.
What should I be thinking of when I prioritize
and when I schedule my workday?
Okay. That's a very good question.
There are lots of different areas to tackle but for example
what worked for me is having,
I work from home. I've been working from home for more than a year now.
And I've done it even before.
So, what really works is this plan.
Having a specific daily schedule for yourself and going by
Very relevant in covid-19 times.
Yeah. Yeah. So, for example for me,
I usually wake up at eight by myself, without an alarm
because I'm used to it.
And then I have my coffee and breakfast
while having a conversation with my business partner.
To discuss the business in general and what we're gonna achieve in the next day
And this day.
Then work for until lunch.
Then to our break.
I realized that taking a long break, resets my energy.
So, instead of saying that I'm gonna work 12 hours a day,
No, I'm gonna work let's say six hours a day.
But those are highly concentrated hours with a large breaks in between
which resets your energy to 90%.
Instead of just trying to go through the day with what's just left.
And even I do that again let's say 6PM.
If I still want to work more, I can just take a big gap of two hours
three hours, and then go again three hours
and those would be very high productivity slots.
Okay. Now, that's just fascinating.
I can talk a lot more about it but I don’t think we have enough time.
What I would love to also hear, I don't get to meet many Lebanese entrepreneurs.
And I'd love to hear a little bit about the Lebanese tech scene.
And your interpretation of it.
You know, coming from Lebanon, having the Silicon Valley experience,
being a successful entrepreneur.
So, talk to me a little bit about what the ecosystem is like?
And what do you see you're rolling it.
Awesome. Yeah.
What I can say about Lebanese people is they're very ambitious.
The problem is they usually have to travel outside and then shine outside.
Because of the very limited opportunities that we have in our country.
But again, the tech scene and the startup scene is relatively big
compared to the Middle East.
Also in Lebanon, we do have VCs, lots of VCs and angels that helped the ecosystem.
But the market is also very tiny.
The Lebanese market is super tiny because we have a population of five million.
Credit card penetration is still low.
So whenever you're building a startup in Lebanon,
you're at least targeting the Middle East.
And not just Lebanon.
And usually, people would just decide to travel abroad, Europe or the US.
Just to be able to get even more and excel more.
Sure. So, the people in the community, do they look up to you
as sort of someone whose done it?
And who got out, shine, and became an extremely successful entrepreneur.
Something that you really read about in the news and on TechCrunch.
And all of the sudden you're coming back.
Do they asked you for advice? How do they perceive you?
Well, it's not just me. We have a lot of successful entrepreneurs.
And whenever we are back home, a lot of the new startups
and people who just experiencing this for the first time
or even couple times that didn't do well,
they always look up to people who have achieved something.
Especially if you went to Silicon Valley.
that's [-]. Definitely.
But even if you went to other places and built something,
they just ask for advice.
They try to see if what's a good way to travel themselves outside
to be able to be successful and to do more things outside.
That makes a lot of sense. So, do you often go back and forth?
Do you get to do it a lot?
Yeah. Yeah, usually go at three times a year.
Oh wow. Yeah, that's a lot. I's a long flight.
Yeah. Oh Yeah.
I'm from Israel so it's pretty much the same amount of hours for a flight.
20-hour flight usually. Yeah.
I got used to it but yeah, it's worth it, I think.
Because you have family there.
Because you have all your history, food.
So, lots of things to look forward to. Yeah.
A hundred percent.
So Dani, what are you excited about now?
There's so much ahead of you.
Where do you see yourself moving ahead?
What gets you excited?
Yeah. Well, at some point, in the past couple of years
I just realized that this is my life.
I'm always gonna be that person starting new companies or,
well actually, it's just more of creating values.
Creating value on the world which for me is starting new businesses and companies.
And this is what I'm doing also right now.
Right now, we're also, since we quit from Mercari
because at the end of the day, you wanna work on something that you own
and you love. So, this is what I'm working on right now.
I'm gonna be working on for a very long time as well.
Of course. Of course. And any specific industries that you're especially curious about
and that you're joining?
Yeah. I'm usually open to different industries especially if there's something new.
I tried things and VR for example last year
Like whenever there's something special, crypto or whatever came up
I just want to explore. Is there anything that can be built that can help actually.
and also make money at the same time.
But I think my strong suit is E-commerce.
Because I've been in it for 10 years.
I know the ins and outs.
Also, I've been in contact with a lot of bigger competitors as well.
Sure.
You want to be indispensable in something in the market.
That you know more than anyone other person probably in the world.
To be able to build some extra value that nobody's seeing right now.
Of course. Dani, 20 minutes is almost up.
But I have to ask you my last question which is also my favorite question.
Can you tell me three words that you would best describe yourself as?
Or, that maybe your co-founder would describe you as?
Looks like an interview question.
Definitely.
What's your weakest point.
I think I'm going for the strongest point. Yeah, I care a lot.
I work way too hard. I'm trying to make too much money for the company.
Yeah, I think it could be Ambitious. That's number one.
To be Persistent, like always trying to follow things through.
And I'm probably a Geek also.
I love it. That's the most important one, I think.
Yeah.
I love it. Dani, thank you so much for the time.
Thank you so much for forming this new friendship.
And I'd love to continue learning from you.
And say hi to your co-founder, a great friend of mine.
And I wish you all the best on your next ventures.
Thank you so much for having me.
Of course. Take care.
Take care. Bye.
--